[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas organizaciones
humanitarias están intensificando la
distribución de ayudas para afganistán
de cara a la llegada del invierno y es
que con la financiación internacional
completamente congelada después de la
toma del poder por parte de los
talibanes en agosto la población se
enfrenta a condiciones económicas cada
día más complicadas el programa de
naciones unidas para el desarrollo
estima que el sistema bancario de
afganistán podría colapsar en cuestión
de meses el siguiente es un reportaje
desigual a sonia que sale y sol en salvo
estos afganos desplazados por el
conflicto lo han perdido todo para
ayudarlos a pasar el invierno las
agencias de la onu están distribuyendo
estos kits de emergencia un esfuerzo
humanitario bajo la seguridad de los
talibanes zona donde estas aguas de afán
de inversis aquí está el quid que recibe
cada familia estos son bidones para agua
portátil dos tipos de jabón esta es una
lámina de plástico la mayoría de la
gente la usa para protegerse del viento
también hay un kit de cocina para una
familia de cinco una manta y un tanque
de gas
allí están recogiendo los productos y se
los llevarán a casa así
más de 100 familias reciben ayuda hoy en
día ghulam haider es una de ellas
fuera del centro los afganos que no
están registrados en la organización
internacional están probando suerte
cuáles son tus dificultades
no tengo trabajo soy trabajador pero
estoy lesionado única
ya no puedo trabajar nadie me emplean
somos una organización humanitaria
nuestra capacidad de ayudar es limitada
pero nuestra capacidad de ayudar depende
de lo que obtengamos 24 millones de
afganos padecen inseguridad alimentaria
hay casi 10 millones más que están a
sólo un paso de la inanición los niños
corren el riesgo de morir y es necesario
hacer más pronto el invierno está a la
vuelta de la esquina y el invierno en
afganistán puede matar en winton en
avión es tan gentil desde que terminó la
lucha las organizaciones humanitarias
están apuntando a áreas que eran
inaccesibles hace tres meses en esta
pequeña habitación vive julián haider
con cuatro miembros de su familia
no tenemos nada para calentarnos
necesitamos carbón necesitamos leña las
mantas no son suficientes en esta casa
de cemento sin calefacción usar este
cubo para lavar la ropa pondremos la
alfombra en la habitación para
aislamiento y los bidones se utilizarán
para transportar agua me alegro de haber
necesitado todas estas cosas se cree que
en la actualidad 24 millones de afganos
necesitan ayuda humanitaria esos son 6
millones más que hace tres meses cuando
los talibanes tomaron el poder en
afganistán
alemania rechazó la propuesta del
presidente bielorruso alexandr
lukashenko de recibir a unos 2.000
migrantes que permanecen varados en su
frontera con polonia a pesar de los
señalamientos de bruselas belarús sigue
negando haber orquestado una crisis
migratoria que se ha tornado en una
humanitaria muchos de los migrantes que
se encuentran en la frontera entre
belarús y polonia son kurdos del norte
de irak y los equipos de france 24
visitaron ese país para tratar de
conocer de primera mano cuáles son los
motivos de estas personas para querer
buscar un mejor futuro en la unión
europea a pesar de los riesgos evidentes
el siguiente es un reportaje de vigil
was a man y que arriesgaban
en un cementerio en el norte de irak el
cuerpo de ghailan desaparece lentamente
bajo tierra el curso de 25 años murió en
la frontera entre polonia y belarús hace
dos semanas su cuerpo acaba de ser
regresado a su familia
y no había comido en cinco días era
diabético pero no tenía su medicina los
guardias fronterizos sabían que estaba
enfermo
según miembros de la familia el ejército
polaco se negó a ayudar y envió el
cuerpo sin vida de ghailan de regreso al
lado bielorruso de la frontera
ya
lo hicieron de una manera tan
dictatorial y poco ética murió en suelo
polaco pero se lo llevaron y lo enviaron
de regreso al otro lado de la frontera
todo fue tan brutal duro debe durar
en las últimas semanas alrededor de una
docena de migrantes han muerto en la
frontera de belarús con europa en el
kurdistán iraquí la gente huye de la
crisis económica y las restricciones a
la libertad de expresión checo de 22
años es uno de los que se están
preparando para irse
este suéter es muy caliente es genial
para viajar también tengo calcetines un
cargador a mano chico recibió su visa
luego de contactar a un intermediario a
través de un mensaje grupal en telegram
pagó cinco mil dólares que incluían el
vuelo y cinco noches en un hotel la
verdad estos son grupos de apoyo
preguntas lo que quieras ahí envías la
pregunta si alguien se comunicará
contigo directamente en un mensaje
privado si ha oído el viaje a belarús se
está volviendo más complicado con
turkish airlines bloqueando sus vuelos a
minsk para los iraquíes pero seco espera
tomar una ruta diferente a través de
catar o los emiratos árabes unidos
india reabrió sus puertas al turismo
después de 20 meses de cierre y aunque
aún existen restricciones para los
viajeros como la vacunación obligatoria
esto representa un verdadero suspiro de
alivio para una industria de la que
dependen miles de personas en el país es
el caso de la ciudad de agra donde la
gran mayoría de la población mantiene
una actividad económica ligada al
turismo y que comprensiblemente fue una
de las más afectadas por el frenazo que
impuso la pandemia de kobe 19 el
siguiente es un reportaje de una bonita
y albany álvarez
todos los días decenas de miles de
visitantes vienen a ver este majestuoso
monumento el taj mahal es el sitio
turístico más visitado de india pero
desde marzo de 2020 ningún turista
extranjero ha visitado este complejo
city bank right wood ha sido guía
durante 25 años antes de la pandemia
ganaban 900 euros al mes atendiendo a
turistas de habla inglesa y alemana pero
en estos días no tiene clientes
en el último año y medio no he tenido
ningún trabajo mi vida ha dado un vuelco
he tenido que sobrevivir con mis ahorros
muchos de mis colegas desesperados
tuvieron que vender verduras frutas o
hacer algún otro trabajo manual durante
este periodo difícil
casi todos los negocios relacionados con
el turismo se han visto afectados esta
tienda de souvenir vio caer sus
beneficios en un
75% esta colorida pared es la misma que
hay en el taj mahal a la mayoría de los
extranjeros les gusta y son caras por lo
que los indios nunca les gusta estas
cosas caras aquí normalmente estaría
todo repleto antes de 2020 solía haber
muchos turistas y no había espacio para
sentarse todos los turistas estarían
haciendo cola aquí para un país que
sufrió una devastadora segunda ola del
cód y 19 el principal desafío para el
gobierno es garantizar la salud y la
seguridad de los turistas en este hotel
de 5 estrellas los preparativos están en
pleno apogeo
todos sabemos que tenemos muchas
aprensión es para que los turistas
regresan al país restaurar su fe es
nuestra máxima prioridad creemos que se
necesitará al menos una afluencia
constante de 6 a 12 meses de estos
turistas que viajen de regreso a la
india para atraer viajeros de regreso al
país al gobierno indio está otorgando
visas gratuitas a los primeros 500.000
turistas
para muchos los aerogeneradores son
piezas tecnológicas extraordinarias y
una respuesta para nuestras múltiples
necesidades energéticas para otros no
son nada más que una mancha en el
paisaje y una amenaza a la biodiversidad
lo que es seguro es que el futuro de la
energía eólica en europa está en plena
ebullición sin embargo la más reciente
controversia tiene que ver con la
dificultad para reciclar las palas de
las turbinas y los equipos de fútbol y
france24 no se explican por qué
decenas de miles de turbinas eólicas
están siendo desmanteladas en todo el
mundo
tras el final de su vida útil de 25 años
pero deshacerse de las palas de forma
respetuosa con el medio ambiente se ha
convertido en un problema creciente
razón constó son materiales sintéticos
de época y en su interior hay fibra de
vidrio en eeuu éstas se apilan y se
entierran en vertederos donde tardarán
siglos en descomponerse pero en alemania
se prohíbe el vertido de palas a euro
generadores por lo que las empresas
están encontrando formas innovadoras de
reciclar las las palas se cortan primero
con una potente sierra y se llevan a
esta fábrica del norte del país una de
las únicas capaces de reciclar el
material las trituran y las mezclan con
otros residuos de plástico o papel el
resultado una materia prima que puede
utilizarse para fabricar cemento
estas fibras de vidrio ahora se mezclan
son un sustituto perfecto de la arena un
material muy demandado en la industria
de la construcción todos ganan en
otros países de europa también están
desarrollando formas innovadoras de
reutilizar la turbina los mástiles y las
palas han terminado por convertirse en
parques infantiles muros de escalada
parques de patinaje o incluso puentes
en italia la ciudad de carrara ha sido
sinónimo de mármol durante siglos sus
canteras están llenas de él y durante el
renacimiento miguel ángel llegó hasta
esa reconocida zona de toscana en busca
de la mejor piedra con la cual esculpir
sus obras maestras hoy por hoy el mármol
de carrara es objeto de una batalla
liderada por las autoridades que
intentan proteger los trabajos locales
siguiente es un reportaje de nuestros
corresponsables en italia
llamado oro blanco en italia el mármol
de carrara es una piedra muy buscada que
ha dado a los escultores locales una
reputación internacional
se siente a gusto living cuesta ahora
somos los guardianes de esta tradición
los últimos en hacerlo somos una pequeña
parte de lo que queda del gran pasado de
carrara era la gran de maestranza de
carga un oficio especializado que se ha
adaptado a los tiempos modernos hoy el
mármol de carrara se utiliza
principalmente para el diseño y la
decoración de lujo pero su
transformación de piedra en bruto a
mármol pulido ahora se realiza
principalmente fuera de italia donde la
mano de obra es más barata las piedras
dejan a italia inconclusa una situación
que el gobierno local quisiera
rectificar entonces han introducido una
serie de nuevas reglas para renovar las
concesiones de las canteras de mármol y
concesionaria estarán obligadas las
empresas que extraen el mármol deben
asegurar que al menos el 50 por ciento
de la transformación del mármol en bruto
se realice aquí esperamos que esto
conduzca a la creación de nuevos puestos
de transporte a necesita ya ya sumar
personas cada año se extraen 4 millones
de toneladas de mármol de las colinas
locales como muchos operadores a franco
le preocupa perder su ventaja
competitiva en el mercado internacional
pues es un veneno
podría ser algo bueno o malo y hacemos
gran parte de la transformación aquí con
esta nueva medida podríamos perder a
nuestros clientes que irían a comprar
mármol a otro lugar algún lugar con
precios más competitivos soy país sin
ver que el y nuestro al tanto el
de acá también hay escepticismo entre
los ecologistas lamentan la falta de
medidas ambientales incluidas en las
condiciones para nuevas concesiones de
mano laborar sólo le cabe que deberían
haber autorizado únicamente las canteras
que producen pocos residuos y también
incluir medidas tangibles para proteger
el medio ambiente y reducir la
contaminación de los ríos hasta ahora
este no es el caso producen polvo de
mármol que termina en los ríos y se mete
al suelo fiscal para penetrar el
ayuntamiento calcula que estas medidas
supondrán el equivalente a 27 millones
de euros para el municipio durante los
próximos 25 años
gracias por habernos acompañado en una
nueva emisión de corresponsables nos
damos cita la próxima semana siga con
más información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom